ننتقل لخبر صار لمحبي البرجر بما انه
بنحكي عن السعرات الحراريه الوجبه الشهيره
ضمن الوجبات السريعه يمكن ان تكون جزءا من
نظام غذائي صحي على ما يبدو تحب اكيد
دراسه حديثه نشرتها صحيفه دي سان الى ان
الكميات المتواضعه من اللحوم الحمراء غير
المصنعه يعني والتي يصنع منها ليس لها اي
تاثير على الصحه طالما ان نظامك الغذائي
جيد وصحي طبعا النتائج هي ماخوذه من دراسه
كنديه تقارن الحميات الغذائيه وكذلك
معدلات الوفيات المبكره والسكتات الدماغيه
وامراض القلب في 80 دوله اثبتت الدراسه ان
85 جراما من اللحوم الحمراء يوميا لا تضر
بالصحه ولكن يجب ان تكون غير معالجه مثل
شرائح اللحم او اللحم المفروم المستخدم في
صنع البرجر الطازج يعني اصنعوها بالبيت
افضل انا اسمعها بالبيت اكثر لمتابعتي
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات